[Music]
hey guys it's Alicia Malone welcome back
to Fandango indie movie Guide and with
Toronto International Film Festival or
TIFF for short starting this week
I wanted to give you my picks of the ten
films I cannot wait to see at Toronto I
want to preface this by saying that I'm
not including any of the films that I
saw at the Cannes Film Festival at
Sundance or South by Southwest that are
playing in Toronto and if you want to
see my favorites for those festivals
then check back at previous episodes in
no particular order the ten films I
cannot wait to see the first one battle
of the sexes starring Steve Carell and
Emma Stone Billie Jean King already a
champion of women's rights is now the
most accessible female player of all
time
I am NOT saying that women don't belong
on the court who would pick up the balls
otherwise oh my god this is based on a
true and famous tennis match that took
place in 1973 between Billie Jean King
and Bobby Riggs
it was quite literally a battle of the
sexes Bobby Riggs was well known as
being quite chauvinistic and Billie Jean
was a fierce feminist this is directed
by Valerie Faris and Jonathan Dayton who
also did Little Miss Sunshine so it's
bound to have a lot of comedy in there
as well it also retains Steve Carell
with those directors and reteam Steve
Carell and Emma Stone who were so great
together in Crazy Stupid Love it's when
we'd want a little bit of what you've
got that's what you can't stand
the battle you've all been waiting this
my next peak downsizing why Alexander
Payne that's why it's described as a
sci-fi social satire it's almost like a
Honey I Shrunk the kids kind of thing
but it's a man who decides to shrink
down and make his life very simple
it sounds so intriguing and it has an
all-star cast including Matt Damon
Kirsten Wiig Christoph Waltz Alec
Baldwin Jason Sudeikis Neil Patrick
Harris bring it on
I Tonya is another movie that caught my
eye this stars Margot Robbie as Tonya
Harding the very well-known and
controversial ice skater
it's a biopic directed by Craig
Gillespie who did Lars and the real girl
and million-dollar arm so it could be
something really unique or it could be
quite conventional but I'm intrigued to
see Margot Robbie in a true lead role
there are a lot of actors / directors
who have movies in TIFF and one that I
cannot wait for is the directorial debut
of Greta Gerwig called Lady Bird it
stars Saoirse Ronan as a rebellious high
school teenager who dreams of getting
out of her very constrictive Catholic
school and moving to New York Greta
Gerwig of course has starred with great
indie directors including people like
Noah Baumbach so I'm really intrigued to
see what her directorial style will be
mother is another film that is going to
be a big buzzy title at the Toronto
International Film Festival because it's
directed by Darren Aronofsky and it
stars Jennifer Lawrence but also that we
know very very little about it all we
know is that it's a psychological
thriller about a couple who has some
uninvited guests he's a stranger we're
just gonna let him sleep in our house
[Music]
hello hello did you know he had a wife
[Music]
mother exclamation point
you give interview it's just never
enough
Gail Mo del Toro is bringing his new
movie the shape of water to the Toronto
Film Festival and it looks like another
fantasy horror magical realism
concoction from this brilliant director
it's set during the Cold War in the
1960s where Sally Hawkins and Octavia
Spencer play two lab assistants who
stumble across some interesting
experiments that are going on
you may think that thing looks human
stands on two legs right but we're
created in the Lord Jim you don't think
that's what the Lord looks like another
beautifully rendered fairy tale I cannot
wait to see the shape of water if I told
you about her what would I say I wonder
[Music]
speaking of great directors and water
submergence is on my list directed by
VIN vendors James McAvoy plays a water
engineer Alicia vikander is an ocean
researcher and the two are trying to
have a romance despite the fact that
they are literally separated by oceans
Paris Texas remains one of my favorite
films of all time so I cannot wait to
see the new film by them vendors another
actor / director where the movie at TIFF
is George Clooney who has suburbicon
this is a big year for Matt Damon in
Toronto because he's also starring in
this one with a script written by the
Coen brothers it's about a family who
turns to blackmail revenge and deadly
consequences after their home is broken
into took everything from us I've to
make decisions like what's best for the
family
[Music]
any progress on the investigation a
mobster got killed a couple of days ago
I'm sorry for his loss life yeah I guess
he probably is too also stars julianne
moore Josh Brolin and Oscar Isaac Martin
McDonagh has a new film which is
premiering at the Toronto International
Film Festival it's called three
billboards outside a Bing Missouri he
was the director behind in Bruges and
Seven Psychopaths and I loved those
films for their quirky mix of comedy and
crime this movie retains Martin with Sam
Rockwell and also in the cast Woody
Harrelson and Frances McDormand
she plays a mother who is really
frustrated with the local police and how
slow they are
in finding her daughter's killer you
didn't have a little hole in the dentist
today did you ah I said of course not it
promises to be more black humour from
this great director this reporter for
one hopes this finally puts an end to
the strange saga of the three billboards
out put an end to show you this is just
a start
why don't you put that on your good
morning Missouri wake-up broadcast [ __ ]
and finally stronger directed by David
Gordon Green starring future husband
Jake Gyllenhaal also Tatiana maslany he
plays a real-life Boston bombing victim
who really encapsulates that idea of
Boston strong having to pick himself up
after going through tragedy where he
lost his legs from the looks of the
trailer it is an emotional roller
coaster and another brilliant role for
Jake Gyllenhaal I can't do this I can't
I can't I can't do it this is the first
time you're in this week and you had
three appointments
to show for you David Gordon Green is
more known for his comedies like
pineapple Express and your highness than
he is for dramas so I'm looking forward
to seeing him in a different light I
wanna walk I'm gonna walk with unions
from there
[Applause]
[Music]
so those are ten films that I cannot
wait to see at the Toronto International
Film Festival I'm gonna try for 20 maybe
even more but those are the ones I'm
really excited about let's put them up
on a list and run through them quickly
you've got battle of the sexes down
sizing I Tanya Lady Bird mother the
shape of water submergence suburbicon
three billboards outside effing Missouri
and stronger write in the comments below
and let me know which films playing at
the Toronto International Film Festival
are you most looking to hearing the buzz
about any on my list may be something
that I've missed or you can always tweet
me at Alicia Malone and I will see you
next week from the Toronto International
Film Festival
[Music]